hi dave hi
anthony house tennessee i'm actually
headed to nashville tomorrow it's
amazing yeah come on brother we'd love
to have you
uh i'm looking forward to it i want to
try one of those cookies i've been
hearing about them for years
so i just moved to denver and i'm
working on baby step 3b as best i can
my current plan is to pause my
retirement and save
all my extra money in like an s p 500
index fund for
about five years but pausing my
retirement for that long scares me a
little should it
yes yes absolutely we usually say about
three yeah
five five feels long how old are you
i'm 31. okay that's that's not the end
of the world
yeah but i just don't i the thing is we
just don't want you to
just not save money for retirement for
an extended period of time
so how much you're trying to save
um i mean kind of five years i was gonna
try to see if i could
manage to pull off 100 grand that'd be
difficult but
saying i'm putting all my bonuses uh 500
a month
i got a relocation package recently i
put half of it in there
um but i do have in the s p thinking
it'd be a five year plan but you're
telling me three now i'm wondering if an
index fund is a great move
well you're probably okay yeah how much
do you make a year will
uh 65. okay how much of a house are you
trying to buy eventually
um over denver i mean by the time three
years is up they could all be a million
plus but uh
i'm thinking can maybe pull off between
like 250 and three to start with a condo
or something
yeah okay okay that's good yeah well you
probably don't need a hundred down to do
300k no um so
uh you may want to shorten the term just
a little bit uh
and or lower the down payment yeah uh
might it might mean both but
i'm five years is max yeah i mean i i
really we usually say three
yeah uh and you know if you've got some
time and you want to go that route i
don't have any problem with it if you're
doing five years and you
ended up with 100 down because of
something happened uh oh you know what
we're not calculating here we're not
calculating the fact your income is
going to go up during that time
yeah i was about to say you've been
generous for five years hopefully
yeah i'm saying three no more than three
man yeah that's that's generally where
we are
you know what i would do is i would do
it do it for three years and then give
yourself permission to change the plan
yes you don't have to keep doing that
just because you started that way you
could go three and go
okay i'm buying or three and you look at
it you go i've made a lot more money if
i go one more year i'll stretch it to
four
i can get there but i don't want this to
drag out and you look up and it's been
10 years
that wouldn't be the way i would change
the plan right so good question